je suis désolé mais une simple ya un
problème avec vos papiers quel était le
souci avec mon passeport
nous avons trouvé un autre paul dedalus
à l'europe qui es tu je ne sais plus je
me souviens tu perds pas les jeux qq
grand mystère mystérieux tu parles tu
fais attention sur liste d'attenté
tu appelles experts étaient dans la
place de ma soeur paule charles pas te
manger des yeux est toujours cet effet
là pourquoi pas ce que je fait
exceptionnel
c'est qu'ils sont ils tu le connais non
qu'elle s'accompagne il souvenu pour te
casser la gueule
ils sortent avec esther désolé mais je
crois que tu es bientôt lourdais y toi
je crois que tu lagaf' même mois puisque
n'est pas et déjà tu m'agace un peu
tout est effacé sinon 3,4 bribes
je veux pas d'un fainéant dans ma maison
me rapporte pas de telles notes
est ce que quelqu'un t'a déjà aimé plus
que sa vie moi je voudrais tu aimais
comme ça
battus par ce jeu fait mystère tu
existes tellement fort comme une
montagne
si tu existes c'est à dire que je ne
suis pas enfermée dans un rêve
je crois que j'ai un peu merdé avec
leicester comment ça je crois qu'on a un
peu couché ensemble
non tu t'installes dans ma chambre tu
couches avec ma femme elles t'ont fait
pas elle aime que toi je l'étais syrie
et je croque esther aussi à sa manière
désir et notre liaison ne connaissent
jamais de fin maintenant elle est avec
moi et avec du jeu ont changé
un jour j'ai donné mon identité je sais
plus si je suis bon moi je sais que tu
viendrais
je confirme je me souviens